this is Mac he specializes in cleaning
the homes of people with hoarding
disorder and is used to waiting through
heaping piles of
clutter but this job presents an
unusually large challenge ma will be
cleaning a six-bedroom home in Illinois
and it's the biggest he's ever tackled
this is just a
nightmare uh I we figh in food from
2013 we've got paint cans that I no
longer have the strength to carry
Mac often cleans solo and does much of
this work free of charge but this job is
so daunting that he's invited two other
cleaners to join him over the next 3
days they'll work together to declutter
and clean as many rooms as
possible normally uh I'm dealing with a
totally different type of cleaning in
other hoarder houses I'm dealing with a
lot of insects and mouse droppings and
pet urine and just a lot of stuff that
you you definitely want to have PPE on
in order to even enter the house this
one was just piles upon piles of stuff
it's the most stuff that I've ever taken
out of a
house this house belongs to a family of
four who declined to appear on camera
due to privacy reasons one of the family
members is believed to be living with
hoarding disorder although he's awaiting
an official diagnosis but even with
treatment experts say relapse can occur
this is the fourth time cleaners have
worked extensively to declutter this
home the last attempt was 5 years ago
rooms in hoarder houses we will often
find rooms that have never been entered
in a decade and one of the reasons that
happens and it's really common is you
have a room that no longer has a purpose
so in this room it's the living room and
the purpose is to watch TV and to relax
if a room loses that purpose because
they they start piling things up then
the purpose of the room becomes this is
where we throw all of our stuff this
place is not what I'd consider a hazard
or a biohazard it's a hazard for
tripping and it's a hazard for fire cuz
they've got an open fireplace in here
and they've got so much clutter that it
becomes a danger hoarding is defined as
persistent difficulty discarding or
parting with possessions regardless of
their actual value it's estimated that
somewhere between 2 and 4% of the
worldwide population have hoarding
disorder it's only day one of this
ambitious project but when Mack and his
team arrive at the house they discover
things already aren't going as planned
so they have cleaned a bunch of stuff
before we got here which normally I
wouldn't like I wanted the big mess and
I wanted to be able to go through the
whole house and make it pretty myself
this is I think a 30 yard dumpster they
filled two of these already over the top
and we're getting ready to fill the
third one if we had more time we would
probably fill 10 of these from this
house so even though I'm a little
disappointed I'm really thankful that
they did have the help Mac and his team
plan to start on what's typically the
hardest room to clean the kitchen
they'll need to pay special attention to
this space to ensure it's sanitary
enough for handling
food then they'll move on to the rooms
on the main level of the house and
finally tackle the basement which hasn't
been entered in 3 years the key tools
Mac and his team use are an emulsifier
to cut through grease a homemade
allpurpose cleaner scouring pads and
razor blade
scrapers so when people asking why this
job takes so long because we have to
check everything like if it's expired or
not or still good
no I'm going get you okay no a big no
for the old
pancakes
no beer we never waste any beer
no holy crap that was a
lot yeah that's pushing an easy 200
lb ma says the biggest challenge of
cleaning a house like this is knowing
what what to keep and what to throw
away there are a lot of people who will
say you're fine to throw away absolutely
everything but they don't really mean
that they mean you can throw away the
junk but you have to decipher what's
junk and what's not there's also the
urge to throw away large armfuls of
stuff and most of the time there's going
to be some stuff underneath it that's
important all right I got one counter
done I'm done beautiful back to the
hotel although cleaning the home will
make it safer and more livable it can be
distressing for people with hoarding
disorder to see their space transformed
people who hoard tend to have a deep
connection with their objects and
removing them can create an experience
of loss which is one of the major
contributors of hoarding behaviors he's
going to come home to a very very
dramatic change and it's going to be a
shock to him and even though most people
will come home and see the change and
think oh my God this is so great you've
cleaned my house he's probably prob not
going to feel that
way as day one comes to a close Mac and
the team have finished most of the
kitchen which they will continue to
clean for the next 2 days on day two
Barbie and Bonnie will also tackle the
sun room and living room while Mac
Ventures into the
basement I'm going to go down to that
basement and do as much as I can on the
basement today um that is going to
completely wear me out if I can get that
out of the way today then that means
tomorrow we can do things like the
dining room and uh get this floor
done I'm going to attempt to tackle this
area this whole area there's this part
of the basement there is a room to my
left and there's a room over here and
they all look like what's behind me this
is going to be extremely difficult
because there is a lot of things that
need to be kept Mac discovers an
abundance of stockpiled food and
supplies including countless jugs of
water jars of marinara sauce bottles of
hydrogen peroxide and 5 Gall containers
filled with something unusual all these
5 gallon buckets those are all filled
with
food yeah I thought they were pain kind
like like that one say macaroni and
spaghetti or something so I'm just going
to stack them all together and they want
to keep them think is still good
probably not people can inherit
characteristics from their parents that
make them more likely to develop
hoarding behaviors grief and loss can
also contribute to this over the years
Mac has noticed patterns in the kinds of
items he finds while cleaning they Stack
Up air filters and medication and
antibiotics and hydrogen peroxide and
alcohol and all of them are unopened and
all of them are there just in case and
they just keep building and building as
Mac continues sorting through jugs of
water and medical supplies he stumbles
on one item in particular he's learned
to never throw away I thrown away shells
twice and in both occasions people were
like have you seen a big bag of shells
that was when we went to Myrtle Beach or
Florida or whatever on a family trip but
they're never displayed as a collection
they're just stuffed in a bag in some
random spot but I've learned over time
that shells are always a momento for
somebody unless they got their house
Infested by clams hey in which case
they're good you much of what Mac finds
in the basement needs to be lugged
upstairs to the dumpsters and so many
trips up and down the stairs with heavy
bags is starting to take its toll right
now my neck is just throbbing and my
right arm I'm pretty sure is injured I
have to be super careful today on what I
lift and how I lift it and how much I
lift it's a little scary because uh if I
tweak my back anymore I'm out of the
picture and I don't want that to happen
back upstairs Barbie and Bonnie are
finishing the kitchen and starting on
the living room and the sun
room I wish I had time to clean all of
this
but
priorities the owner used to sit out in
the sunro every morning and to have you
know scrambled eggs and toast and coffee
and just she likes to bead and I like
knowing those details about the owner
because it lets us know where
emotionally this cleanup is going to
affect them in a positive way as the
crew begins to wrap up for the day the
wife of the person suspected to be
living with hoarding disorder becomes
emotional at the sight of the progress
they've made she was on the second floor
of the house looking over the banister
and just seeing what Barbie had
accomplished and she wasn't even fully
done with the the room uh she broke down
in tears just being able to see the
floor
again so if your partner has boarding
disorder there is a resentment and a
frustration and an anger that builds up
and then finally there's a release point
where everything just comes out and
that's what happened there she's um very
happy to see it opened up uh she's been
in the house for 13 years today's work
was way more exhausting than yesterday
it's a different type of cleaning though
because it's less it takes less of your
mind to do it I guess I'm not really
looking at having to sanitize and to get
out tiny little stains I'm just looking
to get things out of people's way and so
it takes less mental effort but man it
takes a lot more physical
effort It's the final day of the crew's
3-day cleanup and this is their last
chance to organize and declutter as much
of the main floor as possible this is
the day where we have to be basically on
our game and moving quickly we're
wrapping up the kitchen we have a dining
room which is just stuff that needs to
be moved
despite the exhaustion Mac is
experiencing he returns to the basement
and makes another
Discovery God it's like old rotten
garden
seeds and
uh they're not dangerous but they smell
really bad garden seeds when they go bad
smell like raw sewage you have to
breathe through your mouth when you're
putting it in otherwise it'll it'll make
you
nauseous you'll be able to see the story
unfold as you go go through layer after
layer of old stuff the deeper you go
into a horde that's where you start
finding the really rotten stuff and so
it always gets worse before it gets
better excessive acquisition occurs in
the vast majority of cases often times
these items are on sale and therefore
are bought in large
amounts so instead of just getting one
they see the deal and they'll get 20 but
there's even in a big house like this
there's not room to put them all so
you've got this giant pile of shop
lights and you're probably going to find
that with everything from craft supplies
to just random kind of
stuff Night Lights there's an entire
rack of Night Lights what's really
frustrating about this is there's so
much stuff that's necessary and has
legitimate actual use that's actually
real really rare for a hoarder house at
the end of day three the crew has
successfully cleaned the kitchen sun
room Liv living room dining room and
basement and they've removed enough
stuff to fill three 30 yard dumpsters to
the brim we're almost done now compared
to other hoarder houses it's just me
with three of us working here in order
to get the entire house every single
room top to bottom clean we would have
needed a crew of probably 10 plus people
for at least 2 weeks after Mac and his
team leave the family will finish
cleaning the remaining rooms they'll
also hire help to maintain the home I
like seeing a house that is so covered
up with stuff that whenever you get all
of it put away and where it goes and you
get everything cleaned up seeing the
house as it was intended to be seen is
really a cool thing to me and I think
that's part of my my brain that thinks
of rooms like jigsaw puzzles but what
keeps me doing it I think is more the
stress relief that you see happen on the
owner of the house you can see the
stress come off of them at the very end
whenever you leave this one was just
exhausting in every measure just because
of the sheer amount of stuff but it's
it's worth it especially whenever we get
to look around the house and say holy
crap we did that we all did
that